are you a girl that likes to come home
after a hard day and just have a poor
yeah I love a glass of wine today I love
it and never thought that that would be
something I would say I just it took me
a really long time to understand the
benefits I don't know why I know but I
think it was the 3 children hitting a
certain age I was like what are you why
what are you doing why are you not with
your body inside a fridge finding a
glass of wine or you know somewhere we
know that this is in vivo XPS SJP it's
yours
what would Carrie Bradshaw what would
her wine be called if she was creating
one would it be called wonder didn't she
always say I couldn't help but wonder it
could be called meanwhile meanwhile
meanwhile Tribeca you'd have to be in
like typewritten or coupe yeah like like
a typewriter font like an old-school
typewriter computer font maybe like
circa 2002 like that whatever that font
was you mentioned your kids and I was
thinking about this because you do so
much I mean your shoe mine you have this
and your mommy both in a lot of ways how
important is it for you to show and
especially your girls like a woman who's
really got her hand in everything and
doing it well I think what's important
for them to see it you know is that I
like I like being a working person
I'm curious person and so I think really
what I like to share with them is that
being curious has rewards and they don't
come immediately it's an accumulation of
curiosity and asking questions and
seeking out opportunity but I think what
I want to tell them is that curiosity is
the gateway to all sorts of things that
you might not have ever imagined and and
success is not the destination point for
me Experian estimation the destination
is having experiences learning how to be
with other people and what our coping
mechanisms in a challenging day and how
do you get to yes
what do you learn by something that
seems scary or forbidding in some way I
think the more we are out in the world
the more we learn about each other the
more we you know run toward the unknown
the more empathy we build the more
understanding we build the more interest
we have it so I really talk about
curiosity being something that I think
can be really can be can pull them
through their grown-up life I think
especially now when we're feeling
disconnected from one another or afraid
of one another or or there's
conversations that are sort of making
proclamations about people that are
different being scary to us I think it
it is our job as parents to say the
world isn't scary and the people that
are most different our art are not the
people that we should avoid but rather
know better you know do they ask you
more questions your kids about the
entrepreneurial space or like the
creative space I don't know what they
don't ask me about either I think
they're asking questions that you'll
hear in homes across our country and
across the globe which are more like
questions about homework or a
conversation in school or a friendship
or having to make choices so choose
between you know an opportunity and Girl
Scouts and you know with James Wilkie
it's it's its school and interning and
soccer and conversations about
University and you know how to spend
time and where they're rare where is
everybody stuff that's missing that's a
big conversation in our house where is
your uniform where is your thing where
is it thing that's you know I mean it's
perfunctory a lot of its the
conversation would be very familiar how
do you wrap your brain around the fact
that you are having conversations with
your son about college and university
they that's happening he's getting to
that age it's hard to imagine but it's
it's it's incredible I mean he's not
there yet but you know it's it's junior
year
so let's yeah I can't imagine I can't
know what that feeling is to say goodbye
to a child and hope you've left them
with everything they need you know like
here and here
back packs I'm in a water bottle but how
cool is it that they also get to see you
and Matthew teaming up again on Broadway
yeah
why was this the right time cuz I guess
you have you guys haven't been on stage
together since 196 you only buddy right
yeah yeah sheesh yeah came about in a
sort of surprising way our friend John
Benjamin Hickey who's great actor and
and actually about to open in a play on
Broadway called me a year and a half ago
and said listen I've been asked to I've
been asked to curate an evening of some
stuff at Symphony space and would you do
you know let's find a play to read with
Matthew do it I was like of course we
will and we you know poured over plays
and and then we started kind of going
through the Neil Simon Canon you know
and not we were not surprised to
discover how delighted we were to be in
the pages but I think all of us when we
reread plaza suite were just reminded of
that particular plays just skill and how
freaking funny it was how funny it is
but how so how moving it is we're
excited and nervous and our you know
we're each playing three different roles
still get nervous Oh Lord yes Oh God you
don't want to talk to me about yes of
course I do because I still care I think
if I just was like Cavalier I would love
to be that person it it eludes me I've
always wanted to we were just talking
about your dress and I love what you
have on today please tell me that you
are saving some of those iconic red
carpet looks for young kids to either
hand down or just have or yeah I mean
anything that doesn't go back to a
designer is in my possession and we I
think you know often they they
encouraged me to keep but we always send
it
back that's our first you know it's like
the library I always say it's an honor
system you borrow something you return
it in the condition in which or a better
condition in which you were loaned it
but people have been generous over the
years and we have a pretty healthy
archive so yeah we have gotten like a
package like in Sex in the City when she
gets the dress and you've opened it up
and there's like typically I don't get
it typically if I wear it and we we
extend like whatever the conversation is
about returning it often they'll say
keep it well I bite provide the same
token I will say also designers have
called and said can we have that back
for either a museum you know
retrospective of the designer or it's
gonna go on tour or we just frankly want
it back for our own archives in which
case you always say yes but that doesn't
deplete a pretty robust muscular archive
and I don't know who it's for or what
it's for I don't can't imagine why
daughters wanting to wear all of it
but just I think for anybody it's I
think it's a you know it's a it's a
picture of a time spent with a lot of
really talented designers what I
wouldn't give for just a day walking
through that archive and seeing some of
the things you have I mean come on yeah
I think it looks ever no III and that's
why we try to take such such good care
of it we have we let me have them like
probably I would say how much of Sex in
the City
80% it's all like down to every detail
we're gonna play super spill okay so
that's like okay if you don't want to
say take a sip okay if you want to spill
it that's hey all right first things
first
what's the craziest thing you've ever
done when you've had a little too much
to drink I am NOT being coy I just don't
have a crazy thing and means I have to
say I have to drink because I have
nothing I'm gonna drink with you yes I'm
just not funny and anecdotal that way oh
well I got a drink
what would your kids say is mom's most
annoying habit god I have oh I'm sure a
laundry list you know I I tell them they
have to turn their laundry in sight
correct because I like I'm not gonna do
your laundry
if there's a fan in the laundry room and
have to spend all my time on doing your
socks and knickers and that's a good
thing and probably clipping nails like
you have to cook nails son and put nails
on Sundays in my house yeah I'm sure I'm
a really annoying parent what's the most
interest I've got their best interests
at heart
what's the most amount of money that
you've spent on a pair of shoes I would
say back in the day it wasn't so
thoughtful about things like that I
would say I've I've I've I just I've
spent rent
I spent rent on the past I was young and
foolish right and do you know how many
pairs of shoes how many pairs of shoes
do you don't but I don't I don't I don't
shop the way I think people assume I
shop because there is a big distinction
between Carrie Bradshaw and me I try to
get stuff at thrift shops when I can and
use clothing I almost only buy used
clothing so yeah Carrie's had so many
on-screen kisses in Sex in the City
which was your favor
no you're mad like why would I ever in a
mood here
oh I couldn't do that because I've
worked with such great men and women
I've kissed women as well haven't I I
guess it was more set mm-hmm
so I feel like it would just be unfair
to call one I mean they know who they
are if you could bring back any one of
your most famous characters for a reboot
who would it be
well it's hard to ignore the public
outcry for hocus pocus I mean it's
really hard to ignore the deafening call
for a reboot or a receipt well yeah but
I um I mean I think you know to do some
episodes of Sex in the City
I wouldn't call it a reboot I would just
call it a revisit but I would like to
see work here
right now I'd like to see ya where all
of them are I'm curious the world has
changed so much it's changed technology
and social media and really have they
never which is maybe a virtue to because
it would have complicated things even
more so that we've met those characters
never talked about social media which I
just think would be really interesting
and just also sexual politics and me too
movement and time's up has you know been
really steered conversations about
sexual politics and I think Carrie
Bradshaw would be just so greedy to have
to share her feelings and thoughts